in this video we'll talk about positron
emission tomography scan
or
pet scan
now pet scan is a technique that reveals
the metabolic or biochemical function of
your tissues and organ
in this technique the key player is the
positron
which is the antimatter counterpart of
the electron in this video we'll talk
about
mechanism of pet scan
use of pet scan to detect cancer and
other underlying pathological situations
interpretation of the pit scan data
by the way this video was made in
collaboration with the nerd medic
youtube channel
don't forget to follow the channel and
subscribe it
i believe you have heard of different
imaging modalities like ct scan and mri
but why we need another imaging modality
such as pet
basically pet scan
is a functional imaging whereas mri and
ct scan both are structural imaging that
means mri and ct scan gives you a
glimpse of the structural or anatomical
organization of different
organs or tissues
whereas the pet scan gives you a
functional imaging that means it shows
the level of functioning or extent of
functioning of those tissues
now we will learn how pet scan is
performed
now
the pet scan machine is kept in a
separate radiation proof room
in the machine
there's a scanner and in that machine
the patient lies down and the patient is
put into the machine tunnel
in a separate room the operator sits
with a computer where the scan
results are
seen
now as i told you this pet scan uses
radiation and that that's why this has
to be kept in a radiation proof room
now let us understand what biology plays
behind the principles of pet scan
now we all know that human body has
different tissues
like brain and liver
whose metabolic activity require glucose
now glucose
forms atp by different metabolic
pathways and this atp is known as the
energy currency of the cell this energy
currency supplies energy for different
metabolic and cellular activities
now this glucose is present in our
bloodstream whenever the cells require
this glucose they take up the glucose
from the blood
now
now this principle was exploited by the
scientists
to develop a scanning technique such as
pet
so they developed a molecule known as 18
fdg or 18
fluorodeoxyglucose which is a glucose
analog
which emits positrons the antimatter
analog of electron
now let's learn more about 18 fdg
now 18 fpg when injected into the blood
competes with glucose
for getting uptaken in the cells using
similar mechanism
now when cells uptake the 18 fdg 18 ftg
emits positrons now these positrons come
in contact with the electrons that are
already present in different molecules
of the cell
and electron is a matter positron is the
antimatter counterpart of electron so
matter antimatter when they come
together in close contact they undergo a
reaction known as annihilation reaction
now this annihilation reaction gives
rise to gamma rays which
go out
in equal and opposite direction
these gamma rays are picked up by the
scanner or the detector
and the two gamma rays moving in exactly
opposite direction picked up at the same
point of time
is known as the coincidence imaging so
this is the core physics principle
behind the pet scan that is coincidence
imaging
now
there can be two situations now in one
situation
where we have highly metabolically
active
cells
they will take up a lot of glucose and
as they take up a lot of glucose their
fdg intake will also be high and hence
they will
emit a lot of gamma rays because
more more amount of fdg will ensure more
amount of annihilation reaction and from
that we will get more amount of gamma
emission
on the other hand in situation 2 we have
less metabolically active cells they
will take up less amount of glucose
similarly they will take up less amount
of fdg less amount of fdg means less
amount of positron less amount of
positron means less amount of
annihilation reaction so gamma the
emission will be low
now based on these principles let us
interpret the pet scan data
now in situation 1 where we have gamma
emission high
we can see in the image that will give
you a high or dense signal this is known
as a hot spot
whereas when metabolic activity is low
gamma emission is low that gives rise to
a low signal a low density signal known
as a cold spot this hot spot and cold
spot gives you an idea of
different level of metabolic activity in
different tissue
now this pet scan can also detect cancer
like cancer cells are glucose hungry
cells because they have a high level of
metabolism as well as very much
increased cellular activity
so as they take up lot amount of glucose
they also take up a lot amount of 18 fdg
and hence they give high density gamma
emissions or a hot spot as you can see
in the image of this pet scan
but my friend the problem is not over
yet you can see a hot spot near the
lungs in the thorax but
but from this image you cannot actually
tell whether the hotspot is in the lungs
or in the heart or in some mediastinal
organ because the quality of this image
or the resolution of this image is quite
low
and based on this imaging only a doctor
cannot comment on the particular
location of the tumor or the cancer
so a doctor needs more
so here the
scientists again brought about a change
that means
they took the paid scan
similarly they took a cd scan now ct
scan is known or mri scan is known for
their high resolution images and they
give you higher level of anatomical or
structural localization
now using proper softwares they
superimposed these two images to get
something known as a pet ct here you get
the metabolic activity along with the
anatomical localization of that
particular metabolic activity so in that
way you can find out a highly metabolic
spot or a hotspot and also you can know
exactly in which anatomical structure or
in which anatomical location your
particular hotspot lies that gear that
gives you an opportunity to localize the
lesion in a particular way
[Music]
so in summary what we learned we learned
that pet scan technique reveals the
metabolic or biochemical functioning of
your tissues and organs
in this technique the key player is the
positron
which is the antimatter counterpart of
electron and the gamma ray emission
which is picked up by the detector by
coincidence imaging
the mechanism of pet scan we learnt in
detail the annihilation reaction
coincidence imaging gamma ray emission
etc
and finally we learned that pet scan can
be used to detect metabolically active
lesions such as cancer
now we also learned how to interpret the
pet scan data based on the two scenarios
that we took up beyond hot spot and cold
spots
now to get notes and flash cards you can
follow the facebook page and instagram
of animated biologies with urban the
link will be in the description
also you can support this channel so
that we can keep on making high quality
content on patreon also you can go for a
super thanks
by clicking on the super thanks button
on the bottom right corner of the video
and you can contribute using paytm
paypal or upi
now if you wish to connect with arpan
you can find his social links in the
description below also for medicine
related content follow me then medic on
youtube
and all make sure you subscribe to this
channel like the video and share this
video among your peers until then bye
bye see you in the next one